okay let's get back to the phone six 178
340 750 last show before the fourth of
July break checking in with people and
seeing what is on people's minds let's
go to our caller from the 502 area code
caller from 502 what's your name where
you calling from hello yes that's you
yes I'm Paloma and I'm in Kentucky
thanks for taking my call
I was just there's this guy on all right
so hold on you're breaking up you're
talking about it you per youtuber named
what Bob TV Bob TV okay and there was a
mean that you passed along basically
trying to say that Kamala Harris was not
subject to segregation because she was
started going to school after the
integration had already came up it says
this little girl was born in 64 she
knows our school so she was 6 in 69 she
didn't start riding a bus till 73 when
she was 9 and they had not been
segregated since 1943 and I tried to do
some digging and I really couldn't find
anything really definitive seeing as how
is like a state-to-state type thing I I
guess and I was wondering if you knew
anything in regards to that no I don't
so here this is a really good example
based on what I've been talking about
recently regarding not getting overly
involved in arguments where once you
settle the argument it doesn't really
tell you what what you do next so I
guess the the argument that's being made
is based on when I don't know count
Kamala Harris I believe is from
California and I guess she went to
school somewhere in California when she
was a kid is that right right ok so the
argument is that even though even though
there was not sort of a final end point
of full desegregation of schools until
later on in the 20th century the
argument is that
the particular place where Kamala Harris
went to school there had been
desegregation before she started going
to school therefore she was not a victim
of segregation that that's sort of the
argument that that you're repeating was
made right yeah essentially yeah so then
the question is and so what what is the
argument is the idea that Kamala Harris
is wrong on policy because she either
was or was not at a segregated school
like this is why we have to be thinking
about number one I haven't even heard
her talk about this so if she's claiming
she went to some argument in that I
think the largest argument in that was
to was to show that it was kind of like
trying to be an opportunist for a gotcha
moment let me give you an example paloma
because I think that this is if you if
your family left World War two with no
money right before you're sent to a
concentration camp in 1939 or whatever
and then you go out and you talk about
the Holocaust and you talk about
anti-semitism should we say you know you
technically left right before you would
have been sent to the concentration camp
and killed there for you you can't talk
about this issue I mean I just don't
understand what that what do we gain by
doing that and that's why I think it's
like who cares you know is her policy
right on these issues or wrong is she
well-positioned to take on the interests
that are negatively influencing the
country that's what I care about yeah
yeah and that's one thing that I've been
focused on it as well is really from my
perspective the only two
truly progressive people right now are
Tulsi Gabbard and Bernie but they both
have their problematic pasts that she
also has acknowledged but Kamala Harris
she didn't show any regret she had not
convey any regret and the things that
she had done in support of mass
incarceration so that's one of one of my
biggest concerns yeah that's a problem
that's why I've talked about that before
I have not seen her sort of account for
her role there I take issue by idea that
Sanders and Gabbard are the most
progressive of the of the Democratic
candidates running Gabbard actually has
one of the highest percentages in which
she votes with the Trump position on
issues in the last Congress so I've not
seen any empirical evidence that she's
one of the most progressive it seems to
be at least on voting for Trump I
believe it's Gillibrand Bernie and
Warren who least often vote with Trump
that's just one measure though but
Paloma thank you for the call I'm gonna
let you go I'll look into the Camilla
thing but I just wouldn't even worry
about it too much because it's mostly
irrelevant all right thanks again and to
be clear I'm not talking about her role
in the prison industrial complex I'm
talking about whether or not she you
know went to a segregated school
Paloma thank you great to hear from you
appreciate the phone call